l'ordre du jour appelle la question
orale de Monsieur Philippe Leroi madame
la ministre des Affaires sociales et de
la santé Vous AVEZ LA PAROLE mon ch
colèg mon prident madame la ministre
permettez-moi d'attirer à nouveau votre
attention sur les garanties qui
accompagne le remplacement d'un
médicament prescrit par un médecin le
remplacement par un médicament dit
générique dès le mois de dè la fin de
l'année dernière je vous avais interrogé
sans réponse à ce propos ce remplacement
est effectué par le pharmacien qui sous
contrôle administratif de l'assurance
maladie doit chercher à diminuer les
dépenses d'achat de médicaments et
s'expose le di pharmacien à des
sanctions au cas où son efficacité de
substitution ne serait pas jugée
suffisante à l'inverse d'ailleurs le
pharmacien vertueux se voit récompenser
par des primes versé par l'assurance
maladie les logiques économiques propres
au marché du médicament sont encore
compliquées par des systèmes de marge de
de de marge évolutives et qui sont per
quelquefois particulièrement
avantageuses pour les
génériques il serait utile d'avoir plus
de transparence sur le business entre
guillemets accompagnant ce grand ce
grand
marché tout en approuvant sur le
principe cette recherche d'économie je
m'étonne de la responsabilité laissée
aux pharmaciens qui pe sans concertation
modifier la prescription d'un médecin
cela pose des questions d'ordre éthique
et modifie profondément les relations de
confiance entre le patient le médecin et
le pharmacien en outre et c'est le nœud
du problème la comparaison entre les
fiches descriptif d'un médicament et de
son générique ne garantit pas toujours
la parfaite similitude entre les deux
préparations on parle de bioéquivalence
sans toutefois disposer du parfait
contrôle scientifique ou juridique de
cette
notion cette incertitude n'a rien pour
rassurer le patient ayant connu de bons
résultats avec un médicament un
médicament prescrit par son médecin et
se voyant imposer un générique qui n'est
pas en tout point semblable au
médicament jusque là
efficace de nombreux exemples peuvent
illustrer un décalage sérieux entre la
fiche descriptive d'une préparation et
celle de son générique
la similitude chimique entre les deux
préparations n'est pas assurée et aucune
garantie n'est apportée quant à
l'égalité de leur
efficacité les différences entre le
médicament princeps et son générique
peuvent porter sur la nature de la
substance traitante et sur la nature des
excipients il serait important de
disposer
d'expertise visant à encadrer et
garantir la sécurité des autorisations
de mise en marché en conséquent je vous
serai très reconnaissant madame la
ministre s'il vous était possible de
rassurer les
patientségalité d'action entre
médicaments et leur générique est le
seul moyen de maintenir la pérennité
d'une politique d'économie que nous
souhaitons
tous merci monsieur philois madame la
ministre monsieur le sénateur la
ministre des Affaires sociales et de la
santé tient a réaffirmé que les
médicaments
génériques sont autorisés inspectés et
contrôlés par l'Agence nationale de
sécurité du médicament et des produits
de santé et les autorités européennes
dans les mêmes conditions et les mêmes
procédure que toute autre
spécialité en effet les conditions pour
qu'une spécialité pharmaceutique soit
classé parmi les médicaments génériques
sont définis à l'article L
5121 1 5e du code de la santé publique
CSP le générique d'une spécialité de
référence à la même composition
qualitative et quantitative en principe
actif la même forme pharmaceutique et
dispose d'une
bioéquivalence avec le princeps démontré
par des études de
biodisponibilité approprié et mené selon
des normes établies
internationalement ainsi les exigances
des autorisation de mise sur le marché
en matière de qualité et de sécurité
sont strictement
identiqu pour tous les médicaments qu'il
s'agisse des matières premières
principes actif et
excipients des bonnes pratiques de
fabrication des contrôles de la
stabilité
du conditionnement et de
l'étiquetage des inspections sur les
lieux de développement et de fabrication
ont été instauré depuis plusieurs années
et
complètement l'an sm effectue depuis
1999 un contrôle continu en laboratoire
des médicaments générique disponible sur
le marché et vérifie la qualité du
principe actif les performances
pharmaceutiques et du produit fini 10
solutions mis à disposition et la
conformité aux spécifications retenues
dans
l'AMM entre 2007 et
866 génériques et
199 médicaments princeps ont été
contrôlés enfin monsieur le
sénateur le rapport de l'ANSM intitulé
les médicaments génériques des
médicaments à
partentière publé en décembre 2012
dresse un bilan complet des génériques
en France et confirme que la qualité la
sécurité et l'efficacité est assurée
merci merci madame la ministre monsieur
Philippe
Lerois ministre le le sujet est
scientifiquement complexe économiquement
compliqué et vos votre réponse ne
m'apporte pas une complète satisfaction
c'est pour cela que je continuerai à
militer pour une analyse plus approfondi
du marché générique et j'irai jusqu'à
proposer une commission d'enquête
parlementaire à cette à ce
propos merci Monsieur le roi